vamos ahora a nuestra revista de prensa
con Marta Moya Marta Buenos días para
usted Hola Ángela buenos días Vamos a
abrir con el gran tema del día en
Francia porque hoy se juega el futuro no
solo de las pensiones de los franceses
sino también del gobierno de Manuel
macron y por supuesto las portadas
reflejan lo difícil de esta cuestión
cuéntenos así es Ángela hoy prensa
escrita en Francia monográfica sobre la
cuestión de las pensiones que recordemos
el gobierno de macron pretende aumentar
de los 62 a los 64 años hemos destacado
cinco portadas Aunque toda la prensa
francesa Abre igual este jueves
destacamos la portada de liberación que
titula pensiones la hora de la verdad y
encontramos titulares semejantes en las
demás portadas por ejemplo lemont en un
cuadro azul dice reforma de las
pensiones el gran desgarro según una
encuesta anual que se hace sobre la
confianza de los franceses en las
instituciones esta está en su nivel más
bajo desde
2018 desde finales con esa crisis de los
chalecos amarillos destacamos también la
portada de lepaissien que titula el día
más largo como decíamos un día
importante para el quinquenio de Manuel
macron y para la primera ministra
Elizabeth born que está tendrá que
gestionar ese devenir como jefa del
Consejo de ministros la portada de la de
titula como Liberación la hora de la
verdad y para finalizar destacamos el
curríe pickup que titula la hora de
elegir el gobierno todavía puede aplicar
ese artículo 49.3 de la Constitución que
bueno evita el debate parlamentario y
abre un plazo de 24 horas para que se
presente una moción de censura Eso sí la
moción de censura tiene que estar
validada por al menos una décima parte
de todos los diputados y si no se
presenta ese debate parlamentario que
estaba en suspenso al final esa reforma
se aprobaría es una medida que no se ha
aplicado mucho en la quinta pública y
que podría poner en jaque un poco al
gobierno de macron claro y no solamente
son las portadas como nosotros nos está
mostrando sino que en los sitios web de
los medios también se está haciendo el
minuto al minuto de las decisiones que
se han tomado el día de hoy y ya pasó en
el senado y ahora toda la atención se
concentra en la cámara baja así es
Ángela y todos los sitios web No pues
hacen este minuto a minuto con los
puntos clave de la jornada de hoy hemos
destacado dos en Liberación y la que
bueno la liberación Abre por ejemplo con
lo que decíamos no el senado al final
aprueba la reforma de las pensiones
ahora el debate pasa a la asamblea
nacional que es la otra pata del
legislativo y cuyo debate empieza a las
3 de la tarde hora local en poco menos
de dos horas el rechazo masivo de los
sindicatos también está recogido en este
minuto a minuto que planean cerrar todos
los puertos en bueno en protesta por
esta decisión que se va a debatir ahora
en la asamblea nacional también en este
minuto a minuto se recogen las dudas
sobre si el presidente Manuel macron no
presente en el debate en la asamblea y
las palabras de la líder de agrupación
nacional el partido de extrema derecha
marile penn que ha dicho que su partido
respetará la decisión Del parlamento sea
cual sea no nos quedamos que hacer el
cubrimiento Marta Mientras tanto vamos a
cambiar de tema Vamos hasta Estados
Unidos allí los medios ya comienzan a
reaccionar al anuncio del gobierno de
Joe biden de prohibir completamente
tiktok si esta red social no cambia de
dueños si Ángela y esto fue una
exclusiva de ayer del journal pero hoy
la recoge la enviar Que titula bueno que
la administración biden está exigiendo
en estos momentos que la empresa china
tiktok cambie de dueños o la
administración se planteará cerrar por
completo la aplicación en el país que en
Estados Unidos tiene más de 100 millones
de usuarios Por el momento no hay una
Claridad sobre qué tiempos maneja la
administración biden para tener otro
comprador lo que sí sabemos es que a
principios de marzo se firmó una ley
bipartidista por la que se da potestad
al secretario de comercio para prohibir
la aplicación por cuestiones de
seguridad nacional es la primera vez
refleja el emplear que el gobierno
vaiden plantea de manera explícita la
prohibición de la aplicación una cosa
que ya hizo Donald Trump en su gobierno
pero que se quedó en los tribunales y
que se antoja que puede ser el mismo
destino si finalmente biden se atreve a
dar el paso la emplear también te
destaca las declaraciones desde tiktok
que dicen mostrarse decepcionados con
esta decisión de biden y por otra parte
destacamos una opinión del Wall Street
journal que dice que al final prohibir
tiktok sería una mala solución anti
estadounidense cito textualmente
antidemocrática e inapropiada frente a
un riesgo el espionaje y el robo de
datos del que se acusa a bidens la
empresa propietaria de tiktok que no
está aprobado no Porque además dice que
sería inútil centrar solo la atención en
tiktok porque esta cuestión del robo de
datos la bueno la situación de redes
sociales al final eso permea y está en
todas las redes sociales textualmente
dice el Washington post prohibir una
plataforma ignorar las demás nos
resolvería nada mientras que permitiría
que los problemas más profundos se
encontraran absolutamente político vamos
a cerrar ahora con un par de comentarios
de la prensa internacional sobre una
efeméride del día y son los seis meses
de la muerte de Max a mini sí Ángela y
destacamos un artículo de euronews que
con entrevista a varios expertos en
politología y activismo social dicen un
poco Cómo va ese devenir del país
después de seis meses de protestas no
ambos expertos coinciden y hablan para
aeronius que dicen que al final la
muerte de maxa Mini supuso un punto de
inflexión en Irán qué medio año después
la naturaleza de la protesta ha cambiado
y la resolución de la comunidad
internacional debería pasar no solo por
las sanciones sino también por el
aislamiento diplomático pues Marta
gracias a usted y nos vemos mañana
gracias Ángela